I made a video a few weeks ago about how
game awards and Game of the Year are
meaningless and that video was very
specifically directed at Gamers I won't
recap it but you go watch it if you want
doesn't mean literally anything at all
that a bunch of people who don't even
know each other and didn't discuss this
voted for something that you don't agree
with like who cares it doesn't mean
anything to the people who work in the
industry winning awards does matter it's
not biggest deal on the planet like it
you know I don't think people rationally
should be upset if they don't win an
award and that's not why you should be
making games and you should always be
happy for whoever wins but for some of
these people they only get nominated for
game of the year once and thus only have
one opportunity to ever kind of
represent their career on that scale and
and thank people and show appreciation
and and take in what they've done in
their careers that have gotten to that
point where any even meaningless Jury
has acknowledged them like that's your
life the games industry is a very
consuming industry to work in and so
like I said that video was directed at
Gamers not at devs and Publishers who it
does matter to and it makes sense that
it matters to and that's why I wanted to
talk about this year's game awards I'm
not going to be the first person to say
this and I also feel like this
conversation kind of comes up like every
year in different facets but I still
wanted to address it because this year's
game awards to me felt a little I want
to say disrespectful even though it
feels like a very heavy word to use but
I think it's probably the most
appropriate considering the context so
the game awards is certainly um a show
about marketing that's how it funds
itself right and I have plenty of
positive things to say about Jeff key
and the position that he's in and what
he does like I think frankly as an
industry we're lucky to have someone
like Jeff like the fact that an
independent person is of their own
accord creating these shows solely
because they love video games and to
keep it afloat and to pay people and to
make it bigger and cooler and better and
more exciting again as an independent
like there are so many worst cases for
this being done as somebody who also
runs an award show uh I created and I'm
the director slw writer SL producer
whatever of the video game accessibility
Awards it's really hard it's like such a
brutal job and Jeff does it on a scale
that like I can't even fathom but man
when you have an award show and
you have something like indie game won
for sea of stars by sabotage studio and
they are just a throwaway 2C aside um I
believe the statistic was that the show
was like 3 hours or 2 and a half 3 hours
and there were only 30 minutes of actual
Awards the rest of it was trailers and
marketing and to be clear I am okay with
trailers and marketing like I've heard
criticisms that the game awards that
people look it's just a bunch of
trailers I'm like yeah I love those I
recognize that they're advertisements I
get that but I love video game
advertisements like I love getting
excited about the new stuff that comes
in the games industry like we all know
that and we know that that is why Jeff
gets views on the game awards that
people tune in for the reveals they
don't tune in for the awards while every
other award show is declining in
popularity the Grammys the Oscars the
game awards increases year-over-year
almost exponentially like it is such
growth because of the way that the show
operates but while knowing the show is
that this year um I think went a little
too far for comfor so obviously I
already mentioned indie game of the year
basically if you didn't see it they just
they just read it out for best
independent game cocoon Dave the diver
dredge sea of stars and viewfinder and
the game award goes to Sea of
stars congrats sabotage here are the
nominees for best community support and
I had heard before that the game WS does
this when there is nobody there to
accept the award there are alternatives
let them play a video for these people
who made sea of stars who maybe only
have this opportunity one time to be
recognized on this scale and their whole
careers lead up to this point to take
that away from them especially because
for this year especially and last year
so many of these teams worked through
the pandemic which was so difficult for
game development and you have an
opportunity and a platform and and a
name the game awards to have an impact
on their lives forever you know that's a
thing that sticks with them forever and
it's rushed off to run into an overly
long segment with coima and Jordan Peele
which by the way that game look sick
like we saw nothing but I was so hoed
happy to see it not happy to see that
conversation at the expense of winner
speeches so not only are some of them
removed they also got played off and it
was very brutal to watch uh a particular
sh talk about somebody who died and the
music starts they're playing them off I
wanted to note that it sounds like you
can't hear the play it off audio as well
as we could hear it in the room in some
of the streams uh but we also saw that
in person they had a sign saying please
wrap it up which I believe for Boulders
Gate 3 accepting Game of the Year
actually showed up prettyy much around
the time where they were talking about
their colleagues who passed away
apparently they only had about a minute
to make acceptance speeches and
obviously Chris judge's speech went
rather long last year and I get that
they don't want everybody giving an 8
minute speech but a minute one minute
they also because of the ridiculous kid
that came up on stage for game of the
year last year with Elden ring and said
Bill Clinton Rabbi whatever the [__] he
said why God what a waste of time only
allowed two people on stage with the
game awards now which I also think
really sucks because you used to be able
to bring up like your whole team if you
won game of the year and again these
people work so hard for so long to get
so much criticism on the internet all
the time that they get this one
experience and now they can't do it
anymore it does matter to these people
that's that's your life people people
people work so hard and it absolutely
does mean everything to have your
industry your peers the public the
audience like the thing you made of
course that matters so to have it be
rushed through I feel like just made the
show feel very soulless and then my
biggest criticism and this is a thing
that I think they've been doing
repeatedly that I just kind of hate is
all the celebrities there are a lot of
people that they've had present awards
at the game awards that I like I'm
friendly with Simo I would consider him
an acquaintance but people are rightly
criticizing him for getting more time to
talk about the fact that he had his foot
in a cast then most people got to accept
their Awards and while Anthony Mackey
may be in a video game he got to spend
more time telling audience members to
shut up which rightly the heckling was
obnoxious especially being there in
person he got more time to do that than
the people got to accept their Awards
and Timothy sham being chosen to present
game of the year it feels like the game
awards doesn't think
video games are cool enough it feels
like the game awards is embarrassed by
video games Reggie was there Todd Howard
was there Phil Spencer was there these
people who are leaders in our industry
were at the game awards sitting in the
seats in front of me the people who it
would make sense to receive Game of the
Year from and Timothy sham a very young
actor modded controllers 360 who made a
couple of videos and sold 360
controllers that he spray painted for
$10 a piece presented game of the year
it feels like Star [__] and it feels
like the people who make the video games
that are running the show and funding
the show don't matter enough or are not
cool enough or are not Hollywood enough
to present the awards and I just feel
like that is something that I felt about
the Game of Wars for a while but it felt
like much more nagging this year again
Timothy shalam why other than being a
celebrity who is not a celebrity in our
industry you could at least choose
gaming content creators if you want
people with huge f followings it just
feels like look either it's what I had
to do which is like you have to choose a
certain amount of popular people in
order to please advertisers I had to do
that uh with the last year video game
accessibility Awards we got Ryan
Reynolds and I had to pick some friends
who are very popular content creators
because that's the only way that I could
get the sponsorship to pay for the show
it's like here are these numbers these
people are involved and may share things
hopefully it's possible Jeff has to do
that too just to fund the show but I
can't imagine is having it as hard as My
Little Indie Awards show and it just
yeah it feels like Hollywood pandering
it felt that way with Vin Diesel it just
feels like the people making the games
don't matter and I feel like that was
very much sort of escalated this year
like the people who make the games don't
matter to the game awards they really
should be the only thing that matters
yes we all watch for the fun trailers
and yes I have a great time watching
those and those are why I I'm excited
for the most part no I do not ever want
that to come at the expense of the
people who work on making these video
games the people who work on the video
games are the reason we get to enjoy the
trailers and the reason we get to be
excited about what's next and the reason
that we get to experience any of the
things we experience that make this show
relevant my point is really just I get
that it's hard I think I maybe get that
more than most people do I understand
that making an award show is really hard
and I don't have a ton of insightful
stuff to say here other than just like
sharing disappointment that I think I've
seen a lot of my peers also share that
this year especially felt actively kind
kind of disrespectful to game developers
and game development and if anything I
just feel like talking about it and
airing it here and everybody else who's
airing it in theory if you have enough
people airing it um it will be taken
seriously I just feel very sorry for all
of the people who worked so hard to
create things that we all get to enjoy
on our couches at home for them to have
an opportunity to be recognized for that
as people and not just as you know the
splash screen when a game starts up and
it feels like it was reduced and made
irrelevant as as much as possible it
almost feels like the game awards and
Winter game Fest should be two separate
nights or two separate events because
calling it The Game Awards almost feels
dishonest at this point I don't know to
every game developer out there who
worked on any of the games who were
nominated or not nominated this year I
just want to say thank you um I think
you're really [__] cool I've been
inspired by you since I was a child and
I am where I am now because I had the
opportunity to see different developers
speak at different conferences with
different award ceremonies
and to see how passionate people are and
to see how clearly emotional they get
about the things that they've created
that take years and years and years of
their lives that they will never get
back for one opportunity for one kind of
flash in the pan too because everybody
moves on so fast I just um thank you for
making video games I think you're way
cooler than actors like so much cooler
than actors and I would love to hear
what all of you have to say and I hope
that you know that there are a lot of
people that appreciate the work that you
do and the the time that you give us and
the impact that you have on our lives as
well and I think a lot of people feel
the same way that I do don't going to
say I know how to run an a watcher
better than Jeff again I run one I don't
but yeah I don't know I just still felt
the need to make this to say something I
guess to just try to advocate for it
playing music when somebody was talking
about a colleague who worked on the game
who died dude what are you doing